美麗的太太
你知道心臟病
最可怕的地方是什麼嗎
我知道
很快就會讓你沒命
沒錯 馬上教你
1個穴位
讓你在心臟不舒服
喘不過氣的時候
馬上救了自己
胡乃文開講囉
我是你的老朋友 胡醫師
六千人心肌梗塞猝死
1穴位快速自救
台灣每年有超過六千人
因為急性的心肌梗塞而猝死
心臟不舒服如何自救
我要和你分享
一個好用的急救穴
就是極泉穴
它專門幫助你
緩解心悸 心跳過快
極泉穴在腋窩的中間
你用手指掐著極泉穴
然後另外一隻手按著胸大肌
這樣子用力拉扯一下
感覺到微微的疼痛
那就行了
按壓極泉穴
可以讓血液
快速流回心臟
降低心臟的壓力
穩定血壓
甚至你在
危急的時刻
像胸悶 心臟亂跳
甚至身邊有人
昏迷的狀況
都可以靠這一招
救自己一命
當然也可以救其他人一命
非常實用
這樣我要趕快學起來
對 好
心肌梗塞愛找4種人
1動作測血管彈性
你知道嗎
台灣十大死因排行榜裡
心肌梗塞就是第二名
這麼恐怖喔
是喔
我們來看什麼人
容易得心肌梗塞
這四種人
第一種 五六十歲的人
第二種 有三高或者三高家族史的人
第三種 生活作息差的人
像是抽菸 過勞 長期失眠
這些高危險群
第四種 感染或者發炎
天氣溫差大
也容易誘發心肌梗塞
那心肌梗塞
可以自我檢測嗎
可以檢測你的
血管的彈性和循環的狀況
看血管健康或不健康
來 你先把拳頭
握緊幾秒鐘
再立即放開
觀察手掌顏色
恢復的速度是怎麼樣
如果在三秒之內
能夠恢復原本的膚色
恭喜你 血管彈性還不錯
但是如果恢復時間要蠻長的
表示血管可能比較硬
彈性比較差
容易有動脈硬化
或者是循環不良的風險
回家馬上洗澡NG
3招抗寒護心法
天氣一冷你知道嗎
血管會收縮
血壓就可能瞬間爬升高
心臟病 急性中風的風險
也就跟著增加了
我教你三招抗寒的方法
趕快學起來
第一招 回家不要直接進浴室
為什麼
洗熱水澡會讓身體
溫度瞬間劇烈的變化
血管擴張
對心血管不好的人
是很危險的
那我們先喝一杯溫水
讓身體暖起來嗎
很聰明
喝熱水以後
再開啟浴室的暖氣
再放熱水等浴室溫暖了
你再進去洗澡
那冬天泡澡
有沒有什麼要注意的
泡澡時間
不要超過十分鐘
泡太久容易頭暈
就容易摔倒 很危險
第二招洗完澡後馬上保暖
你洗完澡離開浴室
如果遇到冷空氣
血管收縮可能誘發
心肌梗塞或中風
有人洗完澡走出浴室
踩到冰的地板上
結果頭痛
右半身手腳沒力了
口齒不清了
緊急送醫已經腦中風
這麼嚴重喔
那洗完澡一定要
趕快把衣服穿好
對 一定要注意
第三招 床邊放好保暖衣物
半夜起床上廁所
或早上起床的時候
先活動活動手腳暖身
再慢慢下床
把衣物放在枕頭邊
或者伸手可以馬上拿得到的地方
隨時可用 保暖又安心
接下來進一段廣告
四百天的等待
只為這一口精華
玉泰白醬油
屏東老店七十年傳承
日本全濕式工法
堅持長期發酵四百天
讓豆麥醬香更溫潤 甘醇
醬油
選原味才對味
白醬油原料單純
黃豆 小麥 食鹽
砂糖 米
無添加防腐劑 香料 色素
天然安心
只取第一道琥珀色原汁
通過多項認證品質有保障
玉泰白醬油最適合提鮮料理
不死鹹
才吃得出真正美味
生魚片或水餃
沾白醬油最能襯托
清爽鮮美
滷肉用白醬油軟化肉質
吃起來入口即化
醬香滿溢
沾煮滷百搭
涼拌豆腐
燙青菜
加一點味道立刻升級
玉泰白醬油
以傳統醬油的純粹美好
喚醒你記憶裡家的味道
睡太少 睡不好都傷心
心肌梗塞提高1.69倍
你昨天晚上睡得好嗎
睡不好 睡太少
心臟可能就會
可以給你罷工了
睡太少的人 注意喔
研究顯示
每天晚上
睡不到5小時的人
發生心肌梗塞風險比較
睡7到8小時的人
高那麼1.56倍
1倍半以上喔
失眠的人
甚至於高出1.69倍
哇 1.7倍了左右喔
來 總是睡不好的人
你在睡前按一個穴位
它就是神門穴
在手腕橫紋上
小指跟無名指之間
這條線的連結線上面
你左右手各按一兩分鐘
幫助你安定心神
更快速睡好
我要睡著囉
你以為年輕人
狂熬夜就不會出事嗎
有一位大學生
他有高血壓糖尿病的傾向
偏偏很愛熬夜打遊戲
暑假更是玩得沒日沒夜的
飲食是亂七八糟
結果才20多歲
竟然就中風了
這個故事可不是個案喔
好睡眠
才是心臟最好的保養品
那我們睡得越多
是不是越好啊
這事情不是
傻人所想的那麼簡單
不是睡越多越好
每晚睡6個小時的人
心肌梗塞風險
比睡9小時以上的人
還要低耶
黑木耳加2物
遠離中風心肌梗塞
想讓血液順暢
預防中風和心肌梗塞嗎
我給你推薦一道
又好喝又能護心的飲料
木耳紅棗老薑露
本草綱目記載
黑木耳活血止血
它可以抑制血小板的凝聚
預防動脈的硬化
紅棗它裡面含有
cAMP
它可以擴張冠狀血管
改善心肌的營養
增強收縮力
預防心肌梗塞
和心臟的衰弱
再加上老薑 活血醒血
整個血管就通起來了
很順暢的
那麼心臟就更健康
各位 這碗木耳紅棗老薑露的
詳細材料和做法
我會放在最後
你今晚把它截圖起來
明天就來煮煮看
3款飲料最傷心
心血管風險暴增42%
你經常愛喝飲料嗎
果汁 含糖飲料 酒
這三種飲料喝多了
不但傷心而且還傷血管喔
我們先說果汁
我建議你喝果汁
不如吃水果
想想看
你平常一次會吃掉
三四顆柳丁嗎
不會啊
不會對吧
一杯果汁是用
好多顆柳丁榨出來的
糖份很高啊
美國研究指出
每天喝高糖的果汁
一杯以上的人
得到心血管疾病風險
竟然是比不喝的人
高42%
第2個含糖飲料
你每週要喝
三次以上的含糖飲料嗎
珍奶 汽水 提神飲料 咖啡冰沙
會得到什麼呢
小編說
會得到開心啊
當然會開心啊
可是喝多了
身體就不開心了
糖份過量會讓
血糖劇烈的波動
體重就增加了
歐洲研究發現
每天喝兩杯以上
汽水的人你知道嗎
死亡風險比一個月
不到一杯的人
要高17%
心血管疾病 死亡率高52%
這些糖份會讓
三酸甘油脂升高
也就是中性脂肪升高
血管負擔就加重了
長期下去
心臟就超累的
第3個飲料 酒類
你晚上愛喝紅酒或烈酒嗎
長期喝酒會麻痺身體
對心臟可是個大敵啊
能造成高血壓 中風 酒精性心肌病
心律不整的人
還可能心悸加劇
我年輕的時候
也愛喝竹葉青烈酒
入睡很快
但是呢
假如中間忽然的醒來的話
就翻來覆去
我跟你講就再也睡不著了
長期下來
對心血管一點好處都沒有
這三種飲料
真的是少喝為妙
木耳紅棗老薑露做法
新鮮黑木耳1-2朵
老薑6片
紅棗15個
水1200cc
紅棗用刀劃兩刀
將黑木耳 老薑 所有的材料
放入電鍋內鍋
加入水1200cc
在電鍋的外鍋
加1杯半的水
按下開關烹煮
等開關跳起後
就可以直接享用
或是取出薑片
把鍋內的食材
放入果汁機中
打成稠稠的口感
就可以喝
想吃甜一點的人
可以加入適量的糖即可
親愛的粉絲們
我們已經開啟會員頻道了
如果你認同我推廣中醫
照顧自己健康的理念
歡迎每月小額支持
只要花兩杯咖啡的錢喔
或成為VIP贊助者
有你同行
我們才能走得更遠
真心感謝你哦